bath houses are a 5,000 year old
business you can find them in every
ancient culture you'll find references
to bath houses it's a an essential Human
[Applause]
[Music]
Experience Jason Goodman wanted to
recreate the life-changing experiences
he underwent in New York's traditional
Russian bath hous I just moved to New
York going through a little bit of a
rough time I went to the Russian bass on
10th Street and I left there feeling
better than I had in years something
about being in the sauna being in a 190°
room you're very present in the
experience you're right there no matter
what's going on in your noise machine
and so I just got really into sauna cold
plunge not a spa but like more of the
traditional bath
house so he started his own and an old
soda Factory in Williamsburg Brooklyn we
built this place for the hardcore SAA
heads for people who are trying to
optimize their performance their
longevity their overall health but while
the bath house is designed to evoke
ancient tradition what's going on behind
the scenes is Cutting
Edge step behind the old school facade
past the dryers in the back of house
staff and you'll find the pump room
where the waters piped into the baths
are heated up to 100
4° but you'll also find something
extraordinary computers submerged in
fluid serving dual purposes heating the
water and Mining
Bitcoin it kind of clicked in my mind
Bitcoin mining produces heat as a
byproduct I buy energy to create heat he
found YouTube videos of hobbyists using
Bitcoin to heat their Pools and Hot Tubs
instead of cooling the computers with
fans the they're submerged in a
specially engineered biodegradable fluid
that doesn't conduct the electric
current but does absorb the heat which a
heat exchanger transfers into hot water
that moves directly into the pools I was
able to make hot water really easily so
then it became very apparent that this
was going to work Bitcoin mining is
really important let's design a system
and scale it up and it was very easy to
do of course Bitcoin mining wasn't
designed for heating hot tug
it was designed to facilitate a new type
of digital money with a supply that no
single entity can alter or
control there will only ever be 21
million Bitcoin and a central bank
doesn't create new ones computers
scattered around the world running the
Bitcoin protocol to they compete to
solve a cryptographic puzzle that the
protocol makes just hard enough to
ensure it's solved roughly every 10
minutes solve the puzzle unlock a block
of transactions to be validated and
added to the blockchain earn Bitcoin as
the bitcoiners say tick tock next block
the more computing power you have the
better your chances of earning and more
computing power means using more
energy Bitcoin miners are in a
Relentless unquenchable search across
the globe for the cheapest possible
energy it's like a sponge any excess
energy bubbling up past the cost level
bubbling to the point where it becomes
cheap enough for them they will soak it
up that profit-seeking drive for Energy
Efficiency has caused Bitcoin miners to
pop up in unexpected places like
Goodman's bath house where he says the
cost of heating the pools is about the
same as it was before he plugged in the
Bitcoin miners but now with the added
bonus of earning
Bitcoin a dream scenario would be that
every Hotel every major Residential
Building every major office building
starts converting their boiler system or
their heating system their hot water
system over to a system that like we're
using and you have a massively
distributed hard to control mining
Network for bitcoiners keeping the
process distributed and hard to control
is the whole point Bitcoin has many
purposes but to me the simplest is the
most basic which is it's an honest
Ledger why do people save they want a
store of value that's honest and cannot
be manipulated with no Central Bank
there's no way for indebted governments
to print more Bitcoin and devalue its
worth like they have with countless
currencies
worldwide Bitcoin is truly the
transformation of energy into monetary
value in a way that cannot be corrupted
because Bitcoin is not controlled by any
human
organization mining ties the world's
first decentralized digital currency to
the physical world but Bitcoin remains
borderless seeking to exploit in
efficiency wherever it can whether
that's a Brooklyn Bath House an 87,000
ft facility on the outskirts of Atlanta
an unmarked Warehouse in an industrial
area of Venezuela or the small rural
town of Washington
[Music]
Georgia friendly Community probably as
many cows as there our
people Mayor Bill Doolan welcomed
cleanspark one of America's largest
Bitcoin miners to Washington because it
allowed this town of 4,000 to buy energy
at a bulk
discount they're buying a lot of power
from the city and that's that helps the
city with what we're selling to clean
spark the amount of power they buy per
month from us is more than all of our
other commercial and residential
customers
combined one of the great things about
Bitcoin mining is you can be any
anywhere in the world you could be in a
small town in Georgia where the power
we're using used to power a factory that
those jobs left they moved overseas so
now you have a small community that
doesn't have good opportunities we've
come in and we're using you know aged
and underused infrastructure and we're
putting it back to use it's the same
thing that used to be used it's just now
being used for Bitcoin
mining Zack Bradford the CEO and
co-founder of clean spark used to work
in the clean energy sector we actually
selected Georgia for a couple reasons
one business-friendly state of course is
always a good thing but also they are
one of the few places in the US that's
currently still building nuclear power
plants he says that the company
gravitated to a state that relies on
nuclear power not only in search of
profit but to fulfill the company's ESG
mandate to be carbon neutral clean spark
has five mining facilities in Georgia
plus one in Upstate New York powered by
a hydroelectric
Dam here in its Norcross facility clean
spark is using a similar immersion
cooling technique to what Goodman does
in his bath house to cool its 4,300
Bitcoin miners here the mineral oil
absorbing the heat means that clean
spark doesn't have to spend as much
money powering AC to air cool the giant
rooms where the computers are running in
the middle of the day in the summer here
in Georgia right 90° high humidity uh
air cooled environment don't love that
we're removing that environmental Factor
where ambient temperature goes up and
down and immersion is very much a flat
line as compared to air cooled that has
the fluctuations which are primarily
tied to hot
temperatures Bitcoin mining steady
energy appetite could even solve solar
power's biggest
[Music]
problem solar power generates the most
power when the sun's up and middle the
day those it's also the same time most
of us are at work or school or not at
home as a result there's a lot of power
coming onto the grid that actually isn't
getting used or consumed so you have a
couple choices you have to find a place
to store it you have to find a place to
consume it or you actually end up
wasting the power there's a huge amount
of power that goes to waste solar Farms
often shut off panels to avoid
overheating the grid but Bitcoin mines
can absorb that
energy companies are building large
solar mines around the country so you've
heard about the green new deal right so
the government's going to like basically
monetize debt create a bunch of new
money to pay for like uh renewable
infrastructure around the nation right
and maybe other countries will do this I
guess what I would say is that Bitcoin
is the real green New Deal okay so
Bitcoin subsidizes renewable energy
because the projects are made profitable
upon Inception by the ability to
monetize that energy right away and this
acts as a bootstrap so both forign
investors donors uh local investors
communities the government now it makes
more economic sense for them to set up
these renewable plants so rather than
monetizing
debt we can have the market kind of
power this
process Bitcoin mining operations have
located on oil fields to capture energy
from natural gas byproducts that are
unprofitable to transport through pipes
and would otherwise be burned off on
site an energy company is putting miners
in landfills to convert wasted methane
gas into Bitcoin but bitcoin's critics
still consider the energy that's going
to mining to be a complete waste
cryptocurrencies basically have no value
and they don't produce anything
environmentally wasteful
cryptocurrencies completely unnecessary
online play money it's a delusion
basically like somebody else is trading
turds and you decide I can't be left
out some countries have banned Bitcoin
mining the Biden Administration wants to
tax it
heavily Goodman felt the backlash in
Williamsburg when he announced that he
was heating bath house with Bitcoin
mining Bath House in New York is under a
lot of scrutiny from its customers right
now it's Brooklyn Spa is facing backlash
after revealing their pools are heated
by Bitcoin
mining I think that never left that
social media World it didn't spill over
into the real world we got a lot more
support than we got negativity going
through the comments myself what I found
is that the negativity seemed less
educated than the positivity maybe
that's my own
[Music]
bias bitcoin's energy consumption earned
a New York Times front page story this
April proclaiming that Bitcoin miners
are energy Hogs that cause immense
[Music]
pollution the times accused miners of
exploiting Texas utility companies by
selling their own energy energ back to
them at high prices when demand spikes
but miners say the ability to sponge up
and then release energy at a moment's
notice makes the grid more reliable
which is why utilities partner with
them Texas Bitcoin miner Marshall Long
explained how miners Partnerships with
Texas's grid manager helped divert a
summer blackout in a recent live stream
what makes miners particularly good is
because I'm not only a large user I'm a
granular user
so I don't have to turn off my entire
load at once I can just turn off one
minor or 200 miners or 2,000 miners in
order to respond to certain things that
are going on in the grid throughout the
day in September 2023 Texas grid
managers recalled energy from local
miners during an unexpected surge in
demand The Miner shut down and the
lights stayed on bitcoin miners are
actually helping and not
hurting there's very few processes that
can actually be a true flexible load you
have a factory and hey there's grid
congestion and you know power's needed
somewhere else you don't shut the
factory off Midstream in the line or you
risk ruining a product or a material so
we can go away very quickly we can act
like a battery at times where there's
risk to the grid we can respond to
that miners aren't shutting down during
peak hours out of altruism but because
of Market incentives clean spark
monitors Energy prices on a
minute-by-minute basis and shuts down
the moment its operation starts to
become unprofitable freeing up power for
the rest of the
grid what happens when there is no legal
Market welcome to Venezuela where
Bitcoin mining boomed thanks to the
government subsidizing energy to near
zero cost miners sponge up the free
energy while w widespread outages have
become part of everyday life mining has
survived here in a legal Gray Zone which
is why this major Venezuelan Bitcoin
miner who fled to Miami asked us to keep
him
[Music]
anonymous
but even in this gray Market Bitcoin
forces energy Innovation this minor says
he has taken responsibility for fixing
power lines that the government failed
to
maintain
he says the government Crackdown has
intensified so much and the bribes grown
so expensive that he's unwinding his
operation but Bitcoin is so
decentralized and lucrative it's nearly
impossible to
stop China was home to 3/4 of the
world's Bitcoin mining industry until
the Chinese government banned it for
environmental and economic security
reasons in June 2021 when the Chinese
miners dropped out there was more money
left for those that remained more profit
Drew more miners to participate and
within 5 months the computing power
backing Bitcoin was higher than
ever the US now leads the world in
Bitcoin mining in second place still
China because miners are servers so who
decides Instagram servers or the New
York Times servers that are using those
servers to make negative stories about
Bitcoin who decides that that is a moral
use and Bitcoin is an immoral use people
hate Bitcoin for a variety of reasons I
think it mainly comes from a combination
they don't understand its social value
so they think it's a waste and therefore
that they view it as a destructive
environmental Force but once you
understand it has immense social value
and it's having a transformative effect
on on the way we use energy and on how
much energy we use in terms of money
then you're forced to have a new set of
facts and then you can make additional
[Music]
decisions The Choice America faces
isn't whether to allow mining to exist
or not but whether to welcome it here in
a vibrant market economy where it can
bootstrap new energy sources and his
byproducts can create economic value
either way Tick Tock next
[Music]
block